[Music]
it's been a crazy week in america so
let's find out
what happened scientists
in the uk announced this week that they
will start
new vaccine testing trials and will
infect
100 healthy volunteers with the
coronavirus for the study
where are they going to find 100 healthy
people who will voluntarily get
coronavirus oh
yeah a trump rally that's where
great television show 60 minutes
is set to air with an interview with
president trump on sunday
said trump how long will the show be
60 minutes it's in the title how long oh
how long will it be oh yeah
oh how long will the show how long will
this show be
yours is good yeah he's weird hello
yeah no thank you china
president trump china is not a length of
time no
it's not it couldn't cost china no don't
point to your watch and say china those
two things are different i'll see you at
china
no okay you got someone come get come
get president trump
a new poll has found that
a new poll has found that 66 percent of
people of color who are likely to vote
in the election
support former vice president joe biden
and the other 34 are old rich rappers
they are my old friends several cities
in texas were informed recently that
a brain-eating microbe is present in
their water supply
and to that brain eating microbe i'd
just like to say
i've got a yummy yummy brain
you it's the most delicious part of me
i've got a yummy yummy brain for you
this can be beneficial mutually
get started right now and be done by
december cause
this has been a year i don't want to
remember
jump in my ear my mouth or whatever and
freaking chomp away
call me mavis
according to astronomers in iowa the
milky way galaxy is encircled by a
clumpy ring of hot gases
and to be clear the milky way galaxy is
the name of my butt
[Laughter]
a hiker was recently rescued at a
national park in utah after being
missing
for nearly two weeks when asked how she
stayed alive for so long she said
it wasn't easy for us i mean me
and finally minneapolis received six to
eight
inches of snow on tuesday even though
it's only october
but you know who receives 12 inches of
snow year-round
and farm up you know said that my
snowman
12 inches of snow that was the name of
of snow's
cd a cd is how
people used to play music that was the
monologue
tarik did you like it i did it's my
favorite monologue i've heard all day
oh yay how many monologues were you
listening to today oh you better not be
listening to other people
they're there they're there tell them
that's not six feet now that monologue
was filled with real news stories and
hard-hitting facts but
we can't always be verifying everything
that comes out of our mouths
sometimes we need to get to gavin about
things we have heard
you are too right nothing's more fun
than gathered about things you have
heard
speaking of which amber have you heard
any good gossip lately
you are never going to believe what i
heard i
heard about kirsty allie do you remember
kirsty alley
the second love interest on cheers tall
long brown hair used to count as
diversity in the 80s cause she was not
blonde
the very same word on the street is
kirsty alley is voting for donald trump
can you believe it
i can't could you just die i hope not
you never know what celebrities are
gonna turn out to be secret trump
supporters
but you kind of do now
you know me i don't like to gossip
but you know amy coney barrett
the woman who's going to replace rbg on
the supreme court about
yay hi loves the whole super spreader
event
the very same now i heard that in a
racial discrimination case
she ruled that being called the n-word
by a supervisor
didn't create a hostile or abusive work
environment
oh my god that is juicy gossip that is
not
even the gossip you know how she's
well two of her kids are
no yes that lady's kids are
yes there
yes and their mom was like hey employers
slang that
n-word with no consequences can you
stand it
it's like you know how you got that
speech from your parents before your
first job
the how to deal with inevitable racism
you will face at work talk
yes what is she gonna tell these kids
sometimes your boss uses a slur it's a
term of endearment
i mean i don't know her
and i don't know what she's gonna say
but
okay that gives me a bigger it gives me
a big o
i mean what would you be if your parents
didn't have that talk with you
underpaid okay oh also
remember michigan governor gretchen
whitmer
that lady who an armed militia was
planning on kidnapping
beautiful long lady always on tv talking
about stop putting me and my family in
danger
the very same well that are
malicious plans were released and you
will never believe this
what they were planning on kidnapping
the governor
in a pt cruiser please stop your made-up
nonsense it's true you're grown-ass men
planning a kidnapping in a pt cruiser
where are you gonna take her 2010 a pt
cruiser
you better drop your kids off at school
first although if you have a pt cruiser
your kids are in college
what are you gonna do kidnap her and
give her orange slices and a capri sun
a pt cruiser who is planning this
kidnapping the mom some big little lies
a pt cruiser why don't you pt cruise
that car into the trash where it belongs
the pt stands for painful truth and the
painful truth is that you look like a
fool driving that car
you know that game kids play where you
punch your friend when you see a
volkswagen beetle
i used to play that except when you see
a pt cruiser you punch the person who
bought it because they deserve
but you know what i am a fan of you know
what i'm a fan of
gossip
boy that felt good
uh few things in life feel better than a
bunch of delicious
bits of gossip that's right now
we cover gossip and we covered most of
the news but
there's only one more story i'd like to
talk about
last week at a trump rally republican
senator david perdue
mispronounced kamala harris's name and
worse
he did it on purpose but the most
insidious thing that chuck schumer and
joe biden are trying to perpetrate and
bernie and elizabeth and kamal are what
kamala or kamala kamala mama i don't
know
whatever that really made me mad senator
perdue has worked with kamala harris in
the senate for three years
he knows her name and he definitely
knows how to pronounce it
i am sick of white people acting like
kamala is just a name you can't say
guess what if you refuse to learn
someone's name because it belongs to a
person of color
you are a racist you know how i know
because
here are some of the names that white
people always get right
emily ratakowski timothy
chalamet sercia ronan
cher white people love to be like
your name is too hard please meet my
daughter sinead
look here's a little history lesson for
you one of the only things black people
really gained control of in the history
of this country is what we name
our children when black folks got off
slave ships
white people renamed us so when we
finally got some freedom
we decided to take our names back we
took our power back
so you get kisha's and shanika's and
devonte's on your roll call and
there is power in those names and if you
are willing to learn a white
eastern european name that has no vowels
but
can't wrap your head around kamala you
need to ask yourself
why kamala is barely any different than
pamela
and there's not a white person alive who
doesn't know a pamela this
name plays to your skill set
we created names that fill up your lungs
your chest and your whole mouth when you
say them out loud
so fix your mouth and say it right we
have
beautiful melodious names that tell the
story of being black
in america like mine amber mildred ruffa
okay
that's not the best example but uh my
writers names are
chantera jackson dwayne perkins and
oluwa demolade
i did you ebay i'm just letting you know
that now cause
when you try to talk to them and get
their names wrong for the 40th time
we will know exactly where you're coming
from i
am amber ruffin and this is the amber
ruffin show
don't you forget it
[Music]
you